final element of this plan of salvation.
If it's a human debt that he's paying
and that human debt requires also a
human death, Jesus's spirit, how could
he then pay the human debt if he's not
man? Hence the incarnation.
>> That's it. Yep. Hence the incarnation.
Yep. He became a man.
>> See how beautiful Jesus is?
>> It is.
>> You understand his heart, you will fall
more in love with him because you can't
love him enough. And he's infinitely
beautiful.
>> Absolutely. He is infinitely beautiful.
Which um
this
next question or argument it is. So you
you tell me God is all forgiving, all
generous, all powerful. Why would he do
that? Why would what would be why would
this uh sacrifice necessary or pain of
this necessary? Why couldn't he just
wipe his hand and forgive the sin
>> yep
>> of all the world? Which is the next
question. Why couldn't he just say,
"Sam, Muhammad, whoever,
>> I forgive you and it's done and and done
and over."
>> Yes, this is a very complex question
because
we can only go go by what God has
revealed in scripture and by what God
has clearly made known in revelation. So
apart from what God has revealed, we
don't want to then guess and speak when
God is silent. Why do I say that?
Because you have had theologians who
have argued, for example, some say
Thomas Aquinas argued that God could
have simply forgiven if he wanted to,
but chose this way. So I don't want to
say God has to do it this way. So, I'm
trying to be cautious as a Christian
because Deuteronomy 29:29 says that the
secret things belong to Yahweh our our
God, but the revealed things belong to
us and our children. So, I can only go
by scripture.
So, when I see from scripture, God chose
this way in order to demonstrate his
justice, his holiness,
his faithfulness, and his love and
compassion. What do I mean? So just by
going going with scripture,
the Lord God told Adam in Genesis 2
verse 15 to 17, do not eat of the tree
of the knowledge and good and evil. For
in the day you eat of it, you shall die.
Adam went ahead and ate. Now
God said, "The day you eat of it, you
shall die." But Adam and Eve did not
die.
Why did God lie? Because what did the
serpent say? The serpent said, "You
won't die. God knows that in the day you
eat of it, you shall be like God,
knowing good and evil." And ironically,
God said, "The man has become like one
of us, knowing good and evil." It almost
seemed like Satan was not lying here.
Let me bring up the text. Okay, good
question. So, I want to I want to tread
lightly how I answer this. I want to be
try I want to be faithful to scripture
and not read too much into scripture,
right? So we can see the heart of God.
Okay? And you'll see this pattern all
throughout scripture. God will say this
will happen. But then in his love and
compassion and mercy when the creature
responds
in a way let's say if God says look I'm
going to punish you for your sin. You
turn and repent then God doesn't punish
you. He shows you compassion. Because
God loved Adam and Eve. The day they ate
they didn't die. Why? Not because God
went against his word or broke his
promise. It's much deeper than that. For
in the day that you eat from it, you
will surely die. All right. Well, the
serpent said, "No, you're not going to
die." Because Eve said, "But from the
fruit of the tree, which is in the midst
of the garden, God said, you shall not
eat from it, and you shall not touch it,
lest you die." And the serpent said to
the woman, "You will surely not die. For
God knows that in the day that you eat
from it, your eyes will be open, and
you'll be like God, knowing good and
evil. Now, Satan takes partial truths
and corrupts them and mingles them with
lies. So, this is one thing you got to
learn how Satan works from the Bible.
Satan doesn't always straight up lie.
Satan will take a truth or part of a
truth, garble it up, mix it up with
lies, and falsehood to deceive you. How
do I know that Satan wasn't straight up
lying? Because God said in Genesis 3:22
right here he says it
then Yahweh God said behold the man has
become like one of us to know good and
evil. That's exactly what Satan said
what happened. So Satan wasn't lying but
he wasn't telling the whole truth. See
this is how Satan gets you. He'll take a
true statement or part of a truth
statement, then mix it up with lies in
order to entice you with that part of
the truth to then take everything he
says so he can then damn you with the
lies that he mixed in with the truth. So
then what happened though? Because they
didn't die on that day. Here's the heart
of God. This is what happened. I want
you to see the heart of God. And Yahweh
God said to the serpent, "Because you
have done this, cursed are you more than
any of the cattle and more than any
every beast of the field. On your belly
you will go, and dust you will eat all
the days of your life. And I will put
enmity between you and the woman, and
between your seed and her seed. He shall
bruise you on the head, and you shall
bruise him on the Now watch what Adam
and Eve heard, brother. They heard God
say to the serpent, "The woman's seed
will be at war with your seed." You know
what that meant?
>> They're not going to die that day.
>> Because if they died that day, they had
no seed.
>> So, in pronouncing judgment on the
serpent, God gave them hope because he
said, "And they you eat, you will die."
But then they heard God say,
right? God say her seed will be at war
with your war with your seed. Oh, so
we're not going to die. We're going to
live to see seed. And then he further
confirms it when he says to the woman,
I'll greatly multiply your pain and
conception. In pain, you will bear
children. Wow. The assurance you're not
dying today. Why? Cuz I love you too
much to just end your life and either
end the human experience or exper
experiment or start with a new set of
humans. I'm going to give you another
chance, but it comes at a price.
>> Now, watch the heart of God. Adam heard
this. And guess what he calls Eve? He
doesn't call her the mother of all the
dead. He calls her kava, meaning the
mother of all the living.
They heard God's message and they saw
hope. So, if you understand Genesis 3,
it'll actually move you to tears.
Sorry.
>> Praise the Lord.
They heard hope. Notice he didn't say
she's the mother of all the dead. He
heard what God said and said she is kava
from because life will come from her.
Why? Because he heard God say it will be
her seed Adam that will be at war and
destroy the serpent. That means she will
bring forth life, not death.
>> Yep.
>> So what happened? Did God break his
word? No.
>> No. because a death did occur. And here
he teaches you
that I said you will die because I don't
break my word,
but I love you and I don't want you to
die. A death must take place, but it
won't be yours.
Then Yahweh God made garments of skin
for Adam and his wife, and he clothed
them. Well, where do you get garments
made of skin?
He had to make it from something that
had skin, a sacrifice.
>> Yep.
>> And so he goes to Adam and Eve,
I said you would die on the day that you
disobeyed me,
but I love you too much and I can't just
abandon you. However, to keep my word, a
death will occur. There will be a
sacrifice and from that sacrifice I will
clothe your sin and shame so you can
stand before me. This is why God chose
this way to show them I'm a just God.
When I say something I do it I don't
break my word but at the same time I'm a
loving God and I love you too much.
So, I'm going to make a way for you to
be forgiven, but still be faithful to my
word that when sin occurs, a death
results, but it won't be you. And this
points to Christ, the lamb of God.
That's why the Bible says, "Clothe
yourself with Christ." Why? What covered
their sin and shame so they could walk
before God? That garment of skin. Where
did that skin come from? a sacrifice
pointing to Christ, our sacrifice. So
now he can cover us by his blood so that
we are no longer naked before God. Here
it is.
That's what God chose.
You see the heart of God when you read.
>> Yes, sir.
>> That's the substitution. Yes, sir.
>> Right here.
>> Romans 13 11:14 specifically. And then
I'm going to read Galatians 3:27.
He chose this way. Why? to show you he's
a god of his word. If I say something's
going to happen. So if you sin, you got
to die. But I'm also a god of infant
love and I don't want you to die. So
what will I do to show you that I keep
my word but also want you to live? I
will sacrifice
something to take your place in death so
you can live. Pointing to Jesus. Here it
is. Romans 13:1-14. and do this knowing
the time that is already the hour for
you to awaken from sleep. For now
salvation is nearer to us than when we
believe. The night is almost gone and
the day is at hand. Therefore, let us
lay aside the deeds of darkness and put
on the armor of light. Let us walk
properly as in the day. Not carousing
and drunkenness, not in sexual
promiscuity, sensuality, not in strife
and jealousy, but put on the Lord Jesus
Christ. See, wear him like your
clothing. There's your coat of skin,
brother.
>> Yep. That's a robe of righteousness,
Christ himself.
>> And make no provision for the flesh in
regard to its lust. Now, putting on
Jesus means walking like Christ,
acting like Christ, obeying Christ. And
that's why it says Galatians 3:27, for
all of you who are baptized into Christ
have clothed yourselves with Christ.
Here's your code of skin, brother.
>> Hallelujah.
>> That's why Jesus did it. This
>> Amen. That's wonderful.